yeah yeah you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than
itself. There's been a change in the image of thought, that's what it is, that's what it is.
The internal structure, as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the
subject. All right, want to do some uh uh yeah so you're teaching
this tonight. I didn't get a chance to read your lecture because I was reading
the chapter. Cash money man, it's cash money because I put in a little note for boo-boo. Did you read it?
Boo-boo uh yeah but I didn't see my note. Wait, no, it was totally directed the witch by the way.
If the inadequacy is necessary and constitutive, one might eventually begin to suspect that it
isn't an inadequacy at all. Oh yes, that is definitely directed to me.
I was right. I was writing it last night, I uh yeah I mean obviously you can tell I got to the
point at about page four that I was just like okay fucking notes I don't I can't right I can't do this
anymore but I'm trying to run a line with each class like a particular sort of point of emphasis
and hopefully this one is the what it means to do something under erasure. That's really what the
topic of this one is like what he's trying to do with the under erasure thing, right?
I want to read that because that's to me the most mind-bending aspect of this.
That's why that that quote that I use is the epigraph. It was just one random sentence that I came across.
Because I I read it I read it this weekend and then I read it again on Monday and it was the second
with Derrida man I'm just telling you I mean because I've read this five probably five times before
and you just have to read it multiple times and you just have to work through it sentence by sentence.
Like the best way to read Derrida I've decided for me is to write it when I am like reading it and
taking notes and reading and taking like that's the best way to so writing a lecture is actually the
best way to read Derrida for me I found I mean it really is it's like that's what I get it and so
that's the sentence and I think the sentence the sentence that's the epigraph is great I mean it's
I I I was that was one of my favorite sentences I'm just looking at it right now it's such a great
because it's all right there in that like you know that's what usually he'll do that as like a
preface or sentence or something like that but like but I just love that there's only two words the
rationality. But perhaps that word should be abandoned for reasons that will appear at the end of the
sentence, but the sentence doesn't go on in that long torturous way that that he usually does. It's
like which governs the writing best and large and radical, I no longer issues from a logos. It's so
it's pithy it's succinct and it un it erases itself but it doesn't erase itself right it does
sort of both you know I'm going to read it again without the the interjection just quickly for
for listeners, the rationality which governs a writing thus enlarged and radicalized no longer
issues from a logos and then in there is like maybe there's something a little bit odd about beginning
the sentence with rationality because by the time you get to the end of it the logos has been called
the question under erasure right so it's it's sort of how and and the other thing that struck me in
reading grammatology particularly the you know first 90 or so pages it really is an argument like I say
all the time that Derrida inhabits the structure but he doesn't in these 90 pages right like the reading
of Rousseau more so right like the the other the next hundred and hundred and plus but here he makes
an argument and it's and it's almost schematic like there are places where I'm like well he's using
Aristotle as an example and Hegel as an example but he's making a really really big claim saying there's
no exceptions to this that I'm like I can imagine somebody reading this as sort of dissertationy type
thing and being like you're using very minimal amounts of evidence to make this massive claim
right about the history of philosophy you know and it's and he is it's a claim it's an argument
this is dependent upon that now of course he's going to say you know this is dependent on a logic of
metaphysics but metaphysics is not the only thing you know but it's very segmented like the first
like what we read so far doesn't really get at the notion of the trace at all right so it's the
the trace comes later even though there's this sort of metaphoricity move uh so he he makes the move
towards the sensible the the the name for writing in the heart the good writing right is always a
metaphor and so it's metaphoricity it's like that move is is the move of the logic of the trace and
of difference but it's not really uh focused on and not really pointed out you know well here's what
Does not really like a dissertation of it is yes he's making massive claims but you know
how many of these first pages are solely dedicated to getting at the precision of of that claim and
setting it up oh yeah so it's even or just the the target so it's possible to be heard that i mean
the patience required to do that is just truly impressive to me and the stuff on i mean the
stuff on linguistic like i don't know if you guys did you guys just do the 25 first 25 pages
the next stuff on linguistics i mean there's like the sursure stuff i know well so i sort of immerse
myself with the sursure but he's like Jakobsen Helmslev like he's doing the late 60s linguistic
stuff too not just you know the the sursure and its impact so it's like there's there's just big
chunks of that that i'm like i i don't i have nothing to say about it because i don't know it i mean i
don't you know and i and i kind of wonder i mean that's one of the questions that i always have is
i feel like sometimes i'm teaching sursure in order to teach derda and is sursure even relevant
in linguistics anymore like at all like is it or are we keeping sursure alive in order to keep alive
the critique of susur right yeah you know i don't know yeah i don't know if susur is actually even
cited in like linguistics as a field anymore i feel like he's kept alive more in english sort of through
there that's what i mean yeah right well that's what that's what i'm asking like in terms of like
how does this work and and again i don't really i don't know linguistics at all like but i'm guessing
like the chomsky deep grammar stuff like how much how does this play out is there is there a so sore
in like the anglo-american tradition in the last 30 years right or something that is kind of like
you know what susur did in terms of i believe that european linguistics i totally believe susur was
hugely influential structural linguistics like levi-strauss anthropology bart obviously right
like there's huge influences there but does it has it mattered in the last 40 years
in the anglo-american cat i have no idea you know i mean i i i don't know in terms of sort of like
the theoretical groundings but just when i was at south carolina speaking to linguist students because
it was nice that you ran into them in the english department there um and you know they would talk
to me about their projects like it was seemed to be i mean they were usually like ethnographic a lot
of sort of like listening to contented discourse communities and then sort of like breaking down
the sort of structures the socio the socio-linguistic types yeah kind of like empirical studies of
of very much empirical yeah much so about coding but how could you imagine that kind of apparatus
without the the sort of structure of yeah the sign signify or the signifier signified right that's where
i i suspect that Derrida is right in that regard like it is still right in the sense of you can't
imagine a linguistics that doesn't have yeah some version of signifier signified yeah you know like and
now but i do think that you can imagine one that doesn't that doesn't have a version of differences without positive terms
right like right i mean i i mean i'm not saying but but that that it exists but that it's name
i mean that's one of the things that's so sur provides the great linchpin for why there cannot be language
why the concept of language as a totality which is required by him uh can't actually exist so it's just
because because of differences without positive terms right like yeah you can't have a totality
constituted by difference yeah but that was i mean i again i'm i have my sample size is like
three people that i knew at south carolina but i i very distinctly remember in talking with with
them the the sort of the arbitrary like they're they're listening to them talk about the theoretical
foundations it was very much so a matter of the arbitrary designation of you know those terms that are
all based on differentials so like i mean that and and look i don't even think that you need
what i like about the opening arguments here the opening sort of like paving as he starts incredibly
broad and something like linguistics is is very frankly it's a relative it's a certainly a pertinent
um example but it's an example among anything else he brings up the example of you know the biological
writing as as as well and and like the um you know the sort of broader um umbrella that he's creating
here is just some kind of science writing right both a science of writing or the writing of science and
and math and you know to me um it's actually when he's talking about uh math and he's talking about the um
the essential no well the essential or the ideality of the form of identity right that you can't have
math without the concept of one right of of the unified one and then you can start to break that one
down you know and into differentials and into decimals you can say that it's arbitrary you know and this is
This is this is on page 10, by the way, that first full paragraph, um, uh, we have already alluded to the
theoretical mathematics, it's writing, whether understood as a sensible graphy, the manner of writing
and now already presupposes an identity, therefore an ideality of its form, uh, which in principle
renders absurd the quickly admitted notion of the sensible signifier, um, or understood as the ideal
synthesis of signifieds, or a trace operative on another level, or yet more profoundly as a passage
from one to the other, has never been absolutely linked with the phonetic production, and then he goes
on later to sort of like to turn to the um to episteme and historia, right, as the sort of like two sides of
the of the same coin, but like he's what he's setting up here is this sort of three-part movement from
um, uh, from speech as that which is closest to the soul to writing as that which is the representation
of the soul, and then the intensification of that movement to re-articulate or to sort of like
reinterpret that relationship to a prior writing that frank the the phoné, the speaking, is just itself a
representation of, and that, you know, that the representation of of being as presence, which
would be a full, complete writing, you know, the writing on the soul, the writing of truth, the
like, you know, you could use the biological language here, the information of dna, whatever you want it to be
well it i but i back on the math question because to me the math thing here he's in that section on 10
he finds math interesting, like, as something that challenges the metaphysics of presence, right, like
because to me in those moments i mean he goes through a whole series, like starting on nine it's like the
cinematography choreography that all this things of writing the pro program of the living cell, but i mean
i think in cybernetics he names and by under the name of cybernetics i think he means information
what we would call information theory, yeah, right, and that's all of engineering that's all like
the sort of mathematization of things, right, like so what's interesting in in the in regard to the
information theory stuff is that there's no signified, right, there there is no, you know, there's no
signifier signified relation, it's just information and repetition, it's but it's purity, it's the purity of
the information, right, which is why that's all it is, right, which is i mean and and this is, you know
so he sets this up from the very beginning and this is this is where it gets to those questions of
erasure that like if i if i um approach it from this perspective i can see the way that erasure is
working but if i approach from any other perspective it's a little bit too confounding for me, um, i think
this is actually in the epilogue but like this is the the he's like first off he's, you know, contextualizing
you're sort of the exigence of this, like why is he writing about language and writing at this moment
and in some ways, you know, there's and then intensification of the sign of the sign of the
sign, you know, the the sign of of language that has inflated itself to the point of like stretching
beyond its its function, and in doing so it is uh uh it's revealing perhaps a a logic that has always
that's already been there, it required a certain kind of intensification to realize or maybe it's
a mutation, whatever it might be, but you know, the the center of of this this onto theological metaphysics
has generally been presumed to be the the phone either logos closest to the soul, and then everything
else is derivative of that supplemental, like like writing a supplemental, but that supplementarity
is is has effaced itself, that the that um uh that writing itself there's the shift from language the
primacy of language to the primacy of writing, but you have to think of writing a different sense of
writing, a writing that is not the repetition of the phone a but as the pure presence of information
right, the pure presence of the writing of the god, the writing of nature through some kind of natural
affinity, right, and that is, you know, that would like well that now because that's the old one, the old one
is is presumed that there's some pure presence of the idea, the essence or whatever that is then that then
falls, whereas i mean to me, you know, what what he says about math here is within cultures practicing
so-called this is on 10, right after what you said, within cultures practicing so-called phonetic writing
mathematics is not just an enclave that is mentioned by all historians of writing, they recall at the
same time the imperfections of alphabetic writing which passed for so long as the most convenient
and most intelligent writing, this enclave is also the place where the practice of scientific language
challenges intrinsically and with increasing profundity the ideal of phonetic writing and all its implicit
metaphysics metaphysics metaphysics itself, particularly that is the philosophical idea of the epistematic
also of the story, a concept profoundly, that's where it goes, so in that sense it's like the
Mathematization is a challenge, right, uh, because it doesn't, now I think what he's interested in here
and he doesn't, I mean he doesn't spell it out, but my sense of what he's interested in here is how do you
go in a sense, how do you go from theoretical physics, which is an entirely mathematical operation, to like
any conversation about astronomy or anything, right? Like, that's the link that I would, I would imagine
kind of reintroduces, you know, um, but the sort of pure math part of it that's just like, I mean he says
mathematical theory, I mean that's what he names there, uh, mathematical theory is not invested in a
representational relationship at all, you know, um, it is just because it's the ur, right? I mean that the
way that I took it is that that's the, that's the ur, you know, I mean I, I was, I had in the back of my head
Signature Event Context in sort of like thinking about this sort of, you know, uh, language writing and then
another kind of more general kind of writing that governs all of it, right? And I see a different
architecture going on in that essay than I than I do here, right? Because in Signature Event Context the
sort of the the new writing that is revealed is irreducible to, I mean it is iteration, right? It is
citationality itself, it is difference, right? At least what he's doing in the opening here is I I don't see
that yet, I I see the um, uh, it's almost like the ontotheological program of being as pure presence and
the primacy that it places on the the phonetic um, the voice, the breath, everything, uh, sort of like the
near semblance semblance in its intensification, it renders that even that inadequate and then almost
paradoxically it turns to the pure sign, the pure impure information, um, as as its source as its um
criterion of judgment, so that's that's not how I was thinking of it, I mean I'm not sure on that he
doesn't say enough about math and I don't know I don't really understand the things he is saying about
math, right? Um, so to me like that whole passage is look there's been this metaphysics of presence
connected to the ontotheological voice thing, right? And that has been the sort of domain for 2000 years
in the last century or so there are a bunch of efforts that problematize the ease with which we
that is assumed, and now one can find it in very different kinds of areas, one is the importance of
graphing, right? Like the choreography, cinematography, like the the graphing, the notion of a program, right?
Like the the cell, the DNA, writing. So I mean, and what they're doing is they're taking a notion of
writing more important than language, which is not a writing of language, it's just a writing, you know? So
in each of those cases writing becomes not just a derivative, it like the old metaphysical tradition, but
actually an enactment and doing something, and he sees that to me in cybernetics, information
theory, all of these things. Now that's not to say that they aren't then re-hooked to metaphysical
programs in other ways, but to me it seems like he's just saying I'm not the figurehead for this movement
this movement is happening, I'm simply noting it's occurring across a whole series of different fields
that there's a troubling of the metaphysics, so I'm going to now lay out for you the metaphysics and
I'm going to lay out for you the challenges within a philosophical register, not within a choreographic
like military and political writing is another one that he talks about, like I'm not going to talk about
it in those registers, I'm going to talk about it in the philosophical. So to me in that sense math
is the um, math is a location that troubles uh the ease of metaphysics. Now not that that metaphysics
can't be totally reappropriated around the notion of knowledge, right? Like so that that pure math comes
to mean or refer to how do you build the bridge or how you know where is Mars or and things like that.
So it can have a kind of representational efficacy, but well it seems like maybe he's also saying like
these fields in the last century or so are performing this kind of deconstruction of metaphysics without
without being reflexive or conscious of that deconstruction, so I'm Derrida I Derrida I'm going to
kind of articulate uh this problematic, um, as it's performed throughout these various disciplines. I agree,
yeah that's my sense it's exactly what you just said they they're doing they're doing something that
troubles the metaphysics and I'm going to show you the logic of the things that they are doing, right?
You know, um, but he's going to work it in a specifically philosophical register not about
you know the cell or anything else, right? So I think that's a passage I mean it's just fascinating to me
that I'm reading this in the exact opposite lens from the exact opposite lens not I mean I I I agree
with the the um overarching claim that you're making that they're just not claiming that he's you know doing
all of this from you know ex nihilo, that there have been these kind of challenges to it, I'm just taking
the register of the sense of those challenges in a very different way than where I imagined Derrida
is going to going to go with it you know looking at the on on page nine, the the one on um uh uh the
biological program uh the sentence right before that you know all this is to describe uh not only the
the system of notation secondary will be connected with these activities so that which would be the
sort of the the secondary derivative like we're going to write about the way that the cell is doing
but does a metaphor is going to be installed into the very logic of how we think about cells operating
so um for the most elementary process sorry no not only not only a system so writing is not just in
notion of uh notation secondarily connected with the activities it's the essence and content of the
activities themselves, the essence and the writing of these activities, right? Writing becomes primary
exactly. But what sense of writing here is i don't i'm not reading that in the performative iterative
citational sense of writing? oh but that's i think that's totally what he's saying like there i mean
oh yeah like i think it's totally like what's going on here is a a spreading of a logic of writing
of grammatology that i didn't come up with right like i mean as nature said they're doing this thing
i am simply going to unpack the logic of it again not to say that it's not reappropriated in each of
these fields around metaphysics of course but that once you start thinking writing is primary and not
a secondary or derivative component of an idea which is like dna right like in that sense there isn't
some idea of dna it makes cells right so the the writing of you know cellular transcription in that case
and that's where information theories becomes interesting. There's no signified in information
theory right it is simply the repetition of the information itself that's what a signal is is all
pure information and repetition right you know um so that that's where i see yeah like one might also
have to have an incredibly imminent view of that information because i mean just do i mean if we can
stick with the the biological uh example for a second and maybe i'm just sort of like have a a problematic
commonplace understanding of of that logic but when i hear a biologist or just sort of like in common
parlance you know the the the metaphor of the dna is that yes the dna itself is replicated right
but that dna is the information of the body right so like that is it it has that sort of telos
potentiality the exact same kinds of logic that that played or that aristotle would locate in the acorn
uh that you know like within this information that information expressed is an arm or is like
blue eyes or something like that and it's in the replication of that as information
right? but i mean you'd have you'd have to do i mean he just has a sentence so we're taking a lot
i mean all the sentences is it is also in this sense that the contemporary biologist speaks of writing and
the program in relation to the most elementary process of information within the living cell
right like that's all he says about it but i mean my take there is yes i i get your point which is
that's a way of reappropriating it which is that the signified is the sort of dna architecture that
expresses itself in proteins uh or whatever else but you actually think it's not just a code that means
blue eyes it's the blue eyes yeah right like it it's it's not just what's behind blue eyes sorry that was
my who reference no one knows what it's like to be the sad man behind uh but uh behind me can you hear
me right but it's so it's not just a program that is run for something else and i honestly think for
instance he doesn't say very much about it let's just let's agree on that one right like that all but
i think that what he says here is that the logic of writing is has started to spread right and but
and the important part is that that writing is not derivative so when we talk about
choreography right we are talking about graphing writing of bodies right of a core you know so you
are that is that's what you're doing you are not so the writing then becomes a kind of primary operation
for producing actions and and you can see it in cellular biology you can see it in information
theory you can see it in all these places now that he's not saying i don't think that these things
are sort of radicalized he wants to radicalize the implications of taking on this primary writing
thing right i don't think he thinks that they have done that so i mean i i can imagine there's a
critique of cybernetics in here too which is of course it can get re-territorialized and maybe
has to be re-territorialized on some notion of information from and to right like right i mean
guessing one way also like you could say that these fields are taking part in a shift in theoretical
orientation without being cognizant of the implications of that shift so like there's been a
change in the image of thought like to borrow Deleuze's term which enables cybernetics biology
To kind of employ imminently this writing in general that's outside of the metaphysics of presence
but they're not sufficiently or or aware of the implications of this shift so Derrida the exigence
for Derrida is like I'm going to outline these implications philosophically that are kind of like
that's right imminent or latent and radical I mean he'll use that term not like to radicalize the
insights because the reason I don't think it's it's the version that you're talking about Nathaniel
is because like the notion of the book of nature has always been around, right? Like that's not, I mean
that's a commonplace way of thinking of like nature is out there. It's this is book and we read it, right?
so that notion of writing and reading in relationship to nature to me if you're marking a change it's the
change of like I said a kind of information what I think of is Claude Shannon, right? Information theory
this is just stuff from the 40s that I read. I mean, and I don't know very well, right? Like I just sort
of cursory learned it 20 years ago or something but that's where like the materiality of stuff is
nothing but information, right? Like that's it's not like there's information at its core that makes
for the materiality of stuff it is no the materiality of stuff is that's all that a signal
is in information theory is pure information, you know? So how would you then explain something because
I mean a phrase that I hear a whole lot in scientific discourse is like one must gather information as if
like information I mean that that would that to me that is completely opposed to a notion of like
information as citational repetition of material structures
yeah like I let me also say I I'm certain that science doesn't play this out like I mean I think
that's the that critique of science that he has even on the page before where it's like
science there's some things happening in science with math especially especially pure math, right?
where it doesn't care about its representational efficacy it's just following out the logic of
mathematics that's really interesting as it becomes a science it's fucking hooked to the episteme it can't
not be right so it gets re-articulated around knowledge and then it's like well that's that's the old
game, right? Like that is a way of re-hooking this thing, you know? So it's like okay there has to be
some representational payoff for all of these mathematical theory but I don't know what is
more what's more book of nature than saying like math is the thing itself and then everything else
about it is a derivative representation of it it depends on what you mean by that because there
would be no derivative repetition then, right? It would simply be the the book within the realm of
math, right? Because I mean like here's the hook it's like within the realm of math that would that
would be like the pure utterance of god, right? That would be just like it wouldn't be representing
anything else it would only be expressing its own like attributes and its other the infinity of its
own attributes, right? Infinity of its own mathematical, right? Exactly right. That would be like Spinoza's god
right? But then to say anything about it would be to plug that pure you know unspoiled mathematical
you know language non-language like mathematical pure writing the book of mathematics or the pure writing of
mathematics and then plug it into a scientific program that utters truths about it and then
that would have to be all derivative a translation of the more primary you know and that's the same
way but that's the whole so that's the whole problem is at least to me is how do you hook mathematics to
natural languages, right? Like in other words how do you take mathematical equations and translate them
into what it means that then becomes the area of producing episteme and producing knowledge produce you
know and it reintroduces all of the same problematics, right? Because you'd have to go and I think what he
does later is is make the exact opposite move and it's not that there's math and there are representations
about math and then there are writings about the phonetic representations of you know the real you
know ding on zick mathematics is that no we need to take the logic of the mathematics and especially
it's sort of as a as a as a program as something that is constantly unfurling itself that doesn't
have a static center of stable being and then just say that's what's right that's what natural language
is that's what the natural language is right exactly right right and that you know I don't see him doing
that yeah I see him more pointing to like almost like the exact problem that that you just
articulated is that you know we're taking this is I even have it written down here like the you know the
shadows of god that that you know the the sort of um the centrality that god once played as the book
of nature is being distributed across you know a plethora of different things there is the ding on zik
called math the ding on zik, called dna information the ding on zik, of just information writ writ large and
and you know the interesting thing about it is it actually gives a model as not like the source of
of um you know this representational uh um schematic metaphysical schemata is ironically enough also
the way of disabling the entire schemata but i'll give you i'll give you an example because this is
where i think all he's doing like i think that in many ways we're just spending way too much time on this
chunk. I mean, I mean, it's perfectly fine, but I mean like um, we're building it. I think all he's doing is
say is saying this is a trend and a tendency in a lot of fields to think writing to think a kind of
writing that problematizes the old the traditional diagram, that's all he's doing yeah. And because he's
not fully he's not saying they have the radical version at all i'll give you the perfect example is
right after the um, the math stuff on page 10 the other example that he points to is one that's
really clear which is beyond theoretical mathematics the development of the practical methods of
information retrieval extends the possibilities of the message vastly to the point where it is no
longer the written translation of a language, the transporting of a signify which could return
spoken in its integrity it goes hand in hand with the extension of phonography he's just type telephones
right, like i mean all of the things that extend or recording technologies of any kind uh hand in hand
with an extension of phonography and of all the means of conserving the spoken language of making
it function without the presence of a speaking subject, right? Like so this to me is like okay wouldn't
that be the amplification of the phone a and he's like no not at all it's the disconnecting of the
phone a from the voice, right? So it's disconnecting a voice from its sense of presence so in each of
these instances like what does what does the sort of spread of telecommunications do like it it one of
the things that it does is it severs the message from an idea and from an intention and from a sense of
god like that's one of its effects, right? So you know so like now of course you could say it is also a
means for reappropriating it on a massive scale, right? Now we have recordings of people talking and
we can get their their being there, right? Like but he's he's taking it in the other direction and just
saying look there are all these symptoms out there happening in a diverse series of fields that are
attempting to problematize the traditional diagram so first thing let's talk about the traditional diagram
which of course turns out to not simply be traditional right there is yes there is this
ontotheological but then there's also within it the subversion of the ontotheological which is what
enables all of these directions to to you know so it's like there's nothing new to what i'm saying
other than there seems to be a kind of spread or profusion of an interest in this none of which are
terribly radicalized i think to him it's like you know yeah of course phonography certainly
reappropriates presence right right and installs i mean think of the telecommunication stuff in
signature event context where it's like yeah of course it can always be thought as just an extension
of presence by even more powerful means right and it can do that but it has to be able to work at a
kind of absoluteness and the spread of it indicates the possibility of limits you know right yeah maybe i'm
just too hung up on on sort of self-consciousness and intention in here because you know i like again
i think of the metaphor of the the phonograph and you know that is the pure repetition of you know
it's of its source this is a logic of representation and it's just the most kick-ass one because if you
get the high fidelity system but like you look at you look at it like if you if you care about high
fidelity sound fidelity is right in the name and there's the only thing that matters is loss and
failure and you know you sort of like even with sort of like tens of thousands of dollars worth of
you know all analog equipment you know there's still always a loss from the voice to the recording
the recording equipment to its distributions to its production over the speakers and it's just like
the goal is to get as little of that as possible and maintain the purity of the origin exactly to
maintain the purity of the origin and now like darada turns to those kinds of examples precisely to sort
of like show this and this impossibility that's you know a feature not a bug um but i don't think he
thinks that anyone else recognizes that that like the people that he's using as examples here think
they're doing the exact opposite of what he's saying they're doing right right yeah no i think that
that's true but that doesn't necessarily matter right at least in terms of deconstruction right you
don't have to intend to deconstruct your own text it's going to do that work i mean but then
phonography and biological replication everything else would literally be showing the exact same
phenomenon as medieval scribes were but that's the whole point Nathaniel it's always doing both
right like it's not so in other words phonography isn't it is it is a total reappropriation of the
voice and it also pushes the limits of thinking about the voice like the conditions of possibility
conditions of impossibility well it's also you could say like the example of telecommunications like
you could say that that intensifies or makes explicit or makes apparent the ontological condition
that Derrida wants to point out but you don't need the example it just sort of like the the the fact
that the message is divorced from the speaker right that's a condition of writing it's a condition of
speaking over the phone but it's also as he will at least eventually say a condition of speech right
so that's why writing ends up being primary because as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth
it's divorced from the subject and then even prior to that the sort of prior to that the anti-Hegelian
thread is that there's no uh self-present self-consciousness that intends to make the the utterance
right so there's yeah it's like anti-foundationalist to the core paradoxically yeah yeah yeah right
i mean what i see is like the convergence of like all of this stuff that seems on the surface to be sort of
like maintaining or pointing out the integrity of the core you know as sort of like the heralding
of the mathematical unit the heralding of identity the heralding of information as self-present
you know knowledge or information just ready for access yeah it does seem like as you push on those
limits you know Derrida is going to say ultimately you are actually making it easier to see the exact
opposite and i'm going to take it in that i mean i think i think i totally agree like um i think of it
in terms of like the digitization of music as an example right like i remember for a long time it was
like how can this ever be um what how can this ever be commodified because it doesn't work by an
economic logic right like economic logic means either i have it or you have it and if i give it to you
either my copy is devalued because it's secondary replication or whatever right like that's all
all how the logic of economy works but not with digital technologies i can give you a copy that's
literally exactly the same as my copy not degraded in any way at all and so economy economy shouldn't
work right like because there's no scarcity right um and as you as you amp that up you can talk about
sort of making 3D you know 3D printing and the implications of all of that but i mean so on the
one hand this thing should problematize any notion of economy itself premised on scarcity because it
just doesn't work according to that logic on the other hand it's totally clear with Spotify right like
it's it it becomes this again inflated version of an economic model so it it's both right like it's
both and or neither nor or whatever i mean that's where the sort of conditions of possibility conditions
of impossibility and the question of you know which one is phonography like what is this fidelity well
it is both an increasing commitment to faithfulness to the origin and the eradication of the relevance
of the origin right it's really it's really doing both of those things not one or the other
right and it's so easy to say i mean like as you just did that like your copy and my copy are identical
but they're not right i mean that you know they're only identical within an abstract realm of reducing
the song to information which are represented in zeros and ones right but you know the and and so the and
and the differences that sort of matter to us like they're gone but the but that doesn't mean that
the differences have been arrived there still is an economy of site of citationality right and that
sort of like citational path uh sort of like the you know the very same song that i put in scary quotes
here as it passes through my speaker and your speaker are different they're just not important significant
differences for you know our economic lives i would imagine and i don't know if Derrida ever did this
because you know he died what 15 years ago you know like but the digitization the sort of musical
digitization is a really interesting place to me to play this out and i don't know very much i mean this
is boo boo's realm but i don't know very much about this at all but i i suspect all of those questions
are having to be negotiated you know by recording companies distribution companies
Spotify bracket the whole like Joe Rogan controversies and Neil Young and that sort of
shit right but it's simply like it simply becomes a question of how do you make this thing into a
product this thing that doesn't seem to work like most products have always worked um and it seems
like one of the things that Spotify did really well was they were just like you just you change the
Nature of the relationship nobody buys music anymore yeah right okay right like we're going to offer
something that is a membership and is a club that allows or whatever sort of like we have to change
the whole model of how people listen to music but we can still make it a commodity we can still
appropriate it in a commodifiable form we just have to change the nature of of how that commodity
operates you're buying access convenience curation right you're not buying when in fact that access
shouldn't be i mean if it's if it's digital in this regard we and and we do right we can get access to
any music anywhere for nothing you don't know ease of access convenience there there you go right so
that's that's the difference like oh i don't have to go find this somewhere and download it it's like i
just yeah it's right on Spotify i mean the music industry got anti-piracy all wrong at first i
finally figured it out but like the the best anti-piracy isn't to stop piracy it's to make it less
valuable
you know like how many how how many it like um forays into Derrida are there in composition studies
like not like five right yeah like if if that's right Jasper Neil Sharon Crowley like i mean i can
probably list them on my yeah Sanchez Ro Sanchez i mean there's just not very many and you know and i
don't think any of them i mean i think they all do some interesting things but none of them really
tackle the fundamental sort of uh like the two-pronged relationship between writing and onto theology and
writing and iteration and like its significance to pedagogy which is supposedly you know like one of the
cornerstones of composition studies so you know like i think that i think that you could write very
straightforwardly like what are we teaching when we are writing and how and why does you know like
we tend to think of that as a kind of humble um activity and yet it's imported in entire 3000 years
of yeah you're fucking teaching religion like all of you all of you who go into a composition
classroom whether you understand or realize or not you're teaching religion right yes and the
capacity of subverting and mutating religion that's right you're not only teaching religion
but i mean at least you know it's that it's like the boo-boo line like at least be aware at least be
attentive that these are the dynamics that are circulating like when you talk about meaning
there's a whole sort of sensibility and history to that you just think like well what does this sentence
mean you're not just asking a a narrow locatable question right like you're asking a really really
big question the idea that a word has a meaning that whole sense brings a lot with it right like
yes it's so fully routinized that you're like why the fuck would anyone ever ask that question but
that's the whole point is that it's been routinized and repeated and so you are reproducing a structure
right right but man i mean at least for me it just became clearer than it's ever been
the theological yeah the explicitly theological connection to every way that we think about
language right like i mean when he when he says i mean i just remember i was always like you know
there's that sort of John from the book of John like in the beginning was the word and the word
was with God it's like oh that seems kind of interesting and cool like big historical connection
to language and whatever it's like i had no idea the whole thing the whole everything about our
understanding of language is and i mean i i buy this argument it is just like and has always been
the very notion of signifier signified relation is just full on at its core theological and it can't
not be right there's no other way although here's my question if you start thinking of the signifier
as constituting the signified doesn't that change it like because he seems to want to say
right like that there is this is the only history you know and but doesn't doesn't that change things
and again maybe this is the question of Austin right like why sort of Derrida's critique of
performativity is like yeah it does something on this register but it smuggles back in consciousness
in terms of the question of context and intention and in that register i mean maybe that's the response
to it but it just seems to me like he wants to say you know at some level once you have signifiers
and signify it's the sensible and the intelligible that dichotomy which by the way you cannot have
language without that dichotomy like once you have that dichotomy the whole fucking shebang is
onto theological and will always be and i'm like but if you don't see the signified as prime prior and if
you see is the signifier as in some way and so sir does this right so sir says like i'm not really
sure that there's such a thing as thought prior to language right like uh that there's some conjunction
of the two that's necessary he doesn't go into it it's not a determinant it's not sapier
War for anything like that but once you have the idea of the signifier constituting in some way the
signified haven't you changed the diagram or am I missing something? Well, for one thing, I you're
right, I mean there's a reason why the signifier signified are part of the same coin, that is the
sign right? And we have to almost think about this at two levels, like there's the the sign referent
relationship right is is different than the signifier signified relationship right but I think only at
the the at the at the level of level uh that you could like there's not some internal difference between
the two that makes like I think that you could substitute signifier signified for something like you
you know the word um like the sign uh uh cup and the physical cup as well and that's the exact same
logic operative that's governing the relationship between the sound of the word cup and the idea of
the cup of the intelligible and sensible right because you could infinitely subdivide to me, you know, this
this is this is this is a there's a there's an infinite capturing and an infinite subdivision allowable for
that that that sign signifier um uh relationship allows for but if you take I mean so because I even
still provisionally get this point which is like let's just take fucking God and truth out of the
thing right? Like let's just for the moment and I know because because that's so easy to do right
right exactly I know I know I know but let's just let's just totally secularize this as a modern linguist
would right and say like well look you have a perception of something right? So you and through
your perception you form an idea right and that I so the idea is formed through the perception
I see tree a tree right there right like I form an idea and then I embed it in this in a signifier
how how is that theological? You now because God is the tree right? No, no, no, well
God is the presence of my mind to the external world right like God is the pure in other words that that I
when I perceive the tree the the active perception is creating an identity between the idea the
perception and idea that I'm forming and the thing out there right? That's that's the sense of presence
but even even prior to that there has to be an encapsulatable thing called the tree right right
that exists independent of itself that is the or like you know I I I think of this as a word of like a
a chain of communication chains and you know the one of the problems that like Plato runs into you know
over and over again is that the soul isn't primary enough the soul is just another factor in this chain
and you know you have to get to phusis to begin with and then for Plato you have to go up to the eidos
right or to the forms or for the the Christian theologian you have to go to God um and you
know like if you want to if you think that you're secularizing it then you can cut off that last layer
and be like no it's just the world as it is right the soul is already derivative but at least you at
least we have this sense of the soul or mind like having a primary communication a primary communication
with the presence that is the world right like that is but my soul say like let's let's say that I'm
communicating I'm writing about or thinking about or speaking about something that isn't quote-unquote
external to me like say I'm just trying to communicate a feeling right I'm angry okay well there is
the anger qua anger and then there is my self-articulation of that anger qua anger
that that unifies me as a subjective being who in my own internal discourse is closest to the God
that is anger and then I continue that chain of communication by uttering I'm really angry which
then gets to you more or less unscathed but you know that the soul even even in that situation the
the voice that is me articulating my anger to myself is still a step removed from the anger qua anger
and by the way it's a metaphor but that's a big again that's a big presumption like because to me
that's like the kind of pure affect thing for to lose right like that there's this affect and then
there's consciousness making sense of the affect and calling it yes um and so and then there's the
re-articulation of it which is a subsequent and later thing but yeah we're stuck in that prior moment of
because I mean I still feel like God in this diagram
is what governs the certainty of the um of the um equality of mind and perception
right like God is the thing that allows me to be sure that when I see a tree there's a
a fucking tree or that when I feel something and you know like that it's me God as creator God as
lawgiver that was no deceiver you know in Descartes language that like wouldn't pervert you know the
communicative lines between them but then there's also God as as ontological source as being qua being
that would stabilize it governs the relation that says what your mind thinks is there right, like is
it's the thing that that allows you to make an equation between i see a thing there.
right, that would have to be secondary, right, independent of your perception of it there would
have to be a thing there. you would have to have a certain faith that there is a thing there
that it is self-identical and that is capable of perception to begin with, then, and and that would
you know, that pure presence is standing in for a god term, then there's another god term
that is govern that is sort of like governing the possibility of my perception of that thing having
a one-to-one correlation with it so it's like there's a thing there and i have a perception of it but
i need some kind of faith in a god-like mechanism or its natural resemblance or whatever else
that you know the thing that i am perceiving is a perception of it in its reality, so let's go to page
13. yeah, and this is just after uh he says look you can't have a notion of the sign without having a
difference between the signifier and signified like every version has to have something like that
some version of the sensible intelligible yeah, right he says like look this is not just
you know the the religious old school prejudice ones this is like the the modern uh examples of
linguistics and he reads jacobsen roman jacobsen there and he says basically the same thing that
susur says which is this is the the big uh quote on 13 in the middle of 13 there that has jacobsen
quote there it doesn't he doesn't say he doesn't say it's jacobsen but it's jacobsen this is actually
at the bottom of 12 for me it begins the ideal motion no as modern structural thought has clearly
realized i'm on a different oh yeah okay that's 14 for me yeah okay okay um and so the paragraph
under underneath that so i mean he has just said sensible intelligible and it's there so yes but to
these metaphysical theological roots many other hidden hidden sentiments claim theory is just pointing
out the necessity of the sensible intelligible divide like you just have to have that to have
language right the semiological or more specifically linguistic science cannot therefore hold on to
the difference between signifier and signified which is the very idea of the sign without the
difference between sensible intelligible certainly he just pointed that out and this is the part
but also not without retaining more profoundly and more implicitly and by the same token the reference
means to a signified able to take place in its intelligibility before its fall before any
expulsion into the exteriority of the sensible here below which is just to have the idea of something
right like to have the the pure signified well this is the transcendental signified right like a signified
at least the implicit possibility of a pure signified so as the face of pure intelligibility
it refers to an absolute logos to which it is immediately united this absolute logos was an infinite
creative subjectivity in medieval theology the intelligible face of the sign remains turned toward
toward the word and the face of god right
right so in that case to me what what he's saying there is the idea the signified is just an idea in your
any idea which would be which i think would include a perception right like any idea i agree with that yeah
so that that's a signified even prior to my forming it into a word even in my head right um so it's it's
like because that's one of the arguments like the stephen pinker and and other folks are like we can
have ideas prior to you know prior to language right like prior to any kind of language we have ideas and
this whole linguistic determinism thing is bullshit you know but it's like they're actually arguing for
the transcendental signified this notion of a sort of pure idea and pure presence that is
again here would be the question that i would say is why is that theological
i get that it has been theological but why is that necessarily theological do you see what i'm saying
yeah like i mean so what you're talking about is a sign without the need for a referent
right without any kind of referent yeah so even but i mean which
well i think it's theological in at least two ways i mean one historically i'll get to the necessity of
it in a second but i think historically speaking it's it's theological in like the foundation of
rationalism writ large is that god and pre-programs us with clear and distinct
ideas that we can come to without any you know empirical uh right but nobody believes that should
any i mean not no i'm exaggerating but let's let's let's think of this not in some sort of prehistory
time when you know religion tainted all versions of the episteme and everybody thought that everything
Was fucking God manifesting himself? Like, let's think of this in the context of a fully atheistic
secularized, right? Like, scientist who's studying whatever, well, I mean, even I think contemporary
scientists would have a problem with the notion of the tabula rosa, right? That, you know, like biological
genetic sort of like, like, um, composition sort of like pre-shape, you know, our capacity to
engage, right? Ideas is just so, but you could just say, like, well, look, this is not this has nothing to
do with the theological things that you're talking about, this is just the way that the mind works. The
mind, the human brain creates images when it perceives when you have like the Nietzsche sensory data hits
there's some neuronal thing and you form an idea. Like, what's theological about that? Um,
right? I mean, that there's some predetermining structure that that's, um, that upholds it, that's
I mean, that's the historical argument but I think the the more logically necessary argument is that
what does the sign present itself to that there that you need a sense of absolute interiority and absolute
exteriority for something like the purity of a sign without a referent, uh, that presents itself to a an
autonomous bounded subject, and I think it's that purity of relation that is theological and in fact I would
even say that is theological prior to that is the most foundational, like theology, like the very
conception of God requires that logic is the condition of possibility for what we would call, like, any
particular theology. He does point out there's a little aside here on 17 that I that I think is really great
on the point that you're just making, which is natural writing. This is right after the quote, the bible is
the most sublime books. It's probably on maybe on 18 for you, I don't know. But natural writing is
immediately united to the voice and to breath. Its nature is not grammatological but pneumatological. Is
hieratic, very close to the interior, the holy voice, etc., etc. There's much to say about the fact that the
native unity of the voice and writing is prescriptive, right? R.K. speech is writing because it is a law, and I
thought that was a really interesting, it's just an aside point that he's making, which is that think about
when we think of interior voices we think of it as the call of conscience; that would be the most
common way that we come to understand it, and it's always prescriptive, right? It is always don't don't
do that, right? Like the the sort of, you know, Socratic uh daemon version. But that our notion of an
interior voice is always a legislator, right, to the voice that one hears upon retreating into oneself. I
mean, but that is, you know, he talks about like the whole way of hallways, that is the most uniquely you
the one that is untainted. Like, think about the commonplace phrases that's attached to like be
yourself, listen to yourself, and know thyself, right? Like, you know, like when someone tells you in your
high school yearbook don't ever change, you know, it's like find that, you know, that that, you know
center your kernel of self, yeah, to the per the pure kernel of selfness, right? And it's telling to me
too back on my 14 it might be your 13 or early 14, but it's um it's the second paragraph after that
Jakobson quote that you had us on, yeah, um, of course it is not a question of rejecting these notions uh they
are necessary and today at least for us not, um, not a thing that's a different who's that translate
who's that translation? That's a different translation. Uh, the no this is this is Spivak I think I have um
I think it's the 40th anniversary edition. Oh well, oh yeah, it's a because you're just reading that for
for instance and it's minor the changes but there are changes. Yeah, no, I noticed it when I was reading
with yours but they're very small, like a word here and there. Yeah, um, but uh let me just here it is a
question. Nothing is conceivable. Yeah, go ahead. It is a question at first of making evident the systematic
and historical solidarity of concepts and gestures, um, of thought that one often believes to be able to
be separate innocently. The sign and divinity have the same place in time of birth. The epoch of the
sign is essentially theological. Perhaps it will never end. Its historical closure is however designated
and like one way of thinking of this is that like theology exists first and then you know signs sort
of emerge from it and that's what makes all signs theological. I think you could say the exact
opposite as well is that the very conception of this sign allows forward a concept of divinity as pure
presence and there and then as soon as you have to think about the communication of pure presence
presence going beyond itself at all you're into this logic. But why couldn't you say I mean and I'm
being a devil's advocate but I'm being being a devil's advocate in part because I feel like I'm just
not comfortable with those kinds of claims, um, why couldn't you say that voice that I hear that tells
me not to do something or whatever else like that why does that have to be theological? Why can't that
Be yes we could call it still things like my true self my inner self my my inmost interior essence or
whatever but why couldn't I say that inmost interior essence is a product of the of who I've been and who I've
become and all of the things that I've done right like why does it have to be an absolute universal
ahistorical theological like why can't it be just so yeah I have a voice of conscience because of the
person that I am right because of the way that I've moved in the world right so yeah my interior voice
it's it's real um it is and it is my true self but it's my true self not as tainted John it's been
by exposure to fine but I'd be okay but I'm but I'm saying I'm totally okay with that it's like yes so
what I am is always in relation and it's always been sort of spinning out in interactions with
all sorts of alternatives but you would have to have quotation marks around I because you could
not fully bound it well I'm fine with that but I'm fine with that too right but but you see that if
you have to change the logic people would be fine with that right like I think for instance that's
where to me this feels caricatured right like I think a lot of people would be notion would be okay
with the idea of like your true self it would be a different true self had you been born somewhere
else it would still be a true self it would still be the voice of conscience it would still be
the interior essence but it would be an essence constituted by relationality and action and
etc etc yeah think about how scary that oh so go for it Nate no I mean that's not scary that seems
great I mean I think it's great but you're investing the notion of self or the essence of self with
mobility and with the constitutive relationality that at least Derrida is not like the in the
traditional notion of like the essence itself it would be eternal not mobile that's right
not that's right not even affected by otherness but I'm not even sure that that's true right like
I'm not here's what I'm saying is I'm not sure that Derrida isn't straw manning Western caricaturing
yeah yeah you know not I mean straw manning is too strong a word and again I'm not but like
it just doesn't seem that the idea that I'm pointing out here doesn't seem ridiculous I'm not
saying that everyone agrees with it but it just doesn't it seems like something that one could assume a
notion of a true self a voice of conscience that has no connection right to an any kind of absoluteness
or any kind of durability
you
Thank you.